being gay is one of the great blessings
of my life
and it made me a better person and it's
made me a better reporter
um i think it's when you feel especially
when you grow up
kind of feeling like you're on the
outside of things and you're kind of
an observer through things or not
necessarily in the mainstream
last night on cnn's full circle anderson
cooper got very candid about his journey
with his sexuality
after a viewer question i was probably
i don't know seven when i kind of
realized i didn't not sure i knew the
word gay at the time but i
when i realized something was up
something was different
and although anderson told a few people
in high school about his sexual
orientation
he says it wasn't until after college
that he championed his sexuality
it took me a while to kind of fully
embrace it but then at a certain point
i think you know about a year after
college i realized like i don't want to
waste any more time
worrying about this and and sort of
wishing i was some other way
um and i want to you know
embrace who i am it's enabled me to love
the people that i've loved
and um have a life that i've had so i'm
very blessed
and another blessing for anderson well
in april 2020 he became a first-time
father to his son wyatt look at these
pictures
so cute and that means we can officially
call anderson
a daddy
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews
click subscribe or watch these videos